[Music]
guess what day it
is
[Applause]
it's the day to get it done i can tell
you i need to go on a cleanse because uh
yeah it was um the weekend
uh my daughter it was her eighth
birthday
and she's actually here right now my
kids are here at work with me which is
so amazing they have the day off school
and
we'll see how this goes i'm so excited i
love you guys so much my daughter turned
eight this weekend eight
eight eight
i mean when people say that it goes by
so fast
i feel like it's usually people who are
kind of on the other side of it
like looking in the rearview mirror and
they really know how fast it does go by
you know they're trying to warn you to
be present but when you're in it the
truth is it's more like the yiddish
proverb
that the days are long and the years are
short
and when you're looking back at the
scrapbook of your life it seems like an
instant
but i know right now being a parent is
one of the hardest things
the most rewarding but we're all trying
to be superheroes
and you know i had this amazing weekend
where i felt like finally for
you know launching the show i had like
the perfect kid to life
ratio and i was just all in and i knew
exactly what my priorities were in life
and it just felt so good happy birthday
olive
cheers to being eight cheers to me
realizing i can't get away with eating
all that leftover birthday cake and the
macaroni and cheese and everything else
that i have
i mean just i went on a food bender and
uh so yeah i'm gonna be cleansing this
week a little bit
but um listen whether your motherhood or
as i love to call it
other hood i think one of the things
that's really being taught to us right
now in this wild journey
is to be present and although time has
stopped literally it's just stopped we
can't will that clock to move any faster
we can try to be present together
and um appreciate anything and
everything around us in fact jasmine
from chicago i think you have your kids
right
yes yes i have four oh my gosh how are
you juggling four
i have no idea but you know what like
you said we're enjoying the journey it
is an absolute blessing
it really is i i had this like
call with the show this weekend and we
were just talking about you know kids in
this time and
we haven't lived like this in a hundred
years all our societal norms and
agreements are gone
work school everything's different and i
know how trying that is
and yet when i just let everything else
go and focus solely on my kids this
weekend
i knew what the purpose of my life was
and it was so wonderful
but you don't have to be a parent for
that like just finding something
someone that gives you the meaning and
the reason
you have four yes yes four beautiful
babies i wouldn't have it any other way
our
our life is complete my heart is full
cheers to you jasmine thank you for
we can back each other up on finding
that love and goodness in life and just
holding on to it
fruitier life yes
thanks jasmine cheers to you this
morning all right we have a great show
we're gonna kick it off
with one of the classiest women on the
planet the most extraordinary talent
julianne moore
is here more and more and more look at
her oh my goodness
all right and we're going to start with
the news as we like to serve it
sunny side up it's time for drew's news
ma'am i asked you a question
it's drew's news
hi everybody walking to the news desk
all right on drew's news we find all of
those good morsels
that carry us throughout the day and i
love this section of the show because
i have so much fun with the news crew
the best people in the world
and we comb through for these
life-affirming stories of our country
and the people in it
so we're actually shooting our show here
in new york city and
lately the restaurants have been
shifting to outdoor dining and new york
city has felt more like gay perry and i
love it
the new york times reports that the
mayor has said the outdoor dining scene
will continue
year round i know
i mean it is pretty wild when you live
somewhere and
everything changes overnight and the
changes are positive
and then they're gonna stay and new york
has really felt like a bustling european
city and i'm so excited for the island
of manhattan to have a
renaissance aha i'm going to have a
bagel after the show
and i'm going to have it al fresco in
other news
vogue magazine has lizzo on the cover
and i just love her so much she looks
exceptional on this cover like
flawless and in this article she talks
about bodytalk positivity is not even
enough
she would like it to be body normative
she wants to normalize her body and
she's a huge advocate
of the no filter beauty and i
am a big proponent of that as well and
she's doing it in her way
and we love her for that and we cheer
her on endlessly because you have to be
your authentic self in this world
sometimes that's all we have so yay
lizzo
we love you here so much everybody loves
her
okay let's talk about some more women
who are crushing it this story
is everywhere right now okay this female
surfer
rode the biggest wave of the year and
shattered
a guinness world record i know wait
until you see this i mean do we have
footage she's a surfer from brazil
yeah there you go named maya gabiera
and scientists say the wave was
basically 74 feet tall
that's two telephone poles on top of
each other or
five giraffes high and what even makes
this more inspiring is that in 2013
maya had an accident a near-death crash
from a
50-foot wave not even nearly as big and
it took her four years to recover from
it
but she did and now she's back
okay she's getting back up on that old
wave horse
hashtag the old wave horse and she's
riding the biggest
baddest waves in the world now wow if
that isn't a way to show
how you get back up i don't know what is
thank you maya for showing us how it's
done
okay it's time for a beauty junkie alert
all right i'm really into this next
story and this goes out
to all the chins out there all right are
you sick and tired of mask knee which is
acne and
what comes from under your mask you
heard me marie claire has posted a new
soothing facial mask
that fits underneath your ppe it's
called the soothing shield mask by math
bar and it uses
aloe and natural oils i actually love
even taking a little aloe vera plant i'm
from california so this is what we do we
go and hack
a little thing off and then you use the
natural aloe on your face
it's an amazing hack and they sell them
at bodegas all around the city and you
can find them you can plant them
aloe vera is very easily available where
they have like the
herbs and stuff at your local shops it's
there and so you put this underneath
your mask
and listen we can't protect ourselves
enough you know
from covid and then this can help you
with your acne and dry skin and it's a
winning win-win for the chinny chin
chin
[Music]